hey guys how's it going so this is a
pretty requested video what is on my
iPhone and I'm showing you guys this
before the iPhone 7 is out because I
will probably be wiping my entire phone
clean and starting over fresh as I
usually do as new iPhones are released
so this is what is on my iPhone 6s the
day before the iPhone 7 is out we've got
calendar clock Notes App Store settings
visco cam Twitter Google Maps Snapchat
Facebook swarm swarm is kind of one of
those things that I check into your
location used to be 4 square if you guys
are familiar with that whole history
Instagram and then I've got this
photography folder that has dip tick
it's just a simple layout app layout
which I could just use that that's
Instagram's app facetune camera connect
which I use to transfer photos from my
Canon YouTube YouTube Studio Netflix
upload snap and bit cam which is a kind
of a a cool little app so there's my
mouse I can't really use this ever in my
shopping folder I've got Postmates Prime
now Amazon American Air Equinox which is
a gym fly Delta Open Table Yelp and the
Apple store here in my house app I've
got Nest Hue Sonos Hue disco light DJ
Hue party Hue Lights another Hue app and
Uber I don't think Uber belongs in there
but I'm not sure and in my stuff folder
this is where I keep all of the Apple
apps so they're they're all in there
home kit Clash Royale messenger from
Facebook Spotify Gmail play memories
that actually should go into the
photography for to be honest with you
that's what I used to connect my Sony
a7s Mark I to my phone so I can get
photos this is a photo uploader that was
for Snapchat it's stupid I'm deleting it
Pokémon go very crucial Saucy that
allows you to get alcohol delivery to
your house very important stutter
tumbler go90 this app I don't even know
how it got on my phone it's like the
weirdest thing ever it's called like my
boyfriend plastic surgery I don't ever
remember downloading it and I have no
idea how I got on my phone and I've
never even played it cuz you have to
like actually pay to play it it's the
stupidest thing ever like pregnant mommy
surgery like what is this I think I need
to start a series of crazy IOS games
because this is ridiculous pregnant
mommy surgery try it for free no that's
how you get to the crazy parts of the
Apple Store Eve that's a period tracker
Indie Car app that's from when I went to
the Indie 500 and I've been keeping
track of all of the fun that's been
going on there Dropbox my AT&T Penguins
engage that's Twitter's little um I
guess their answer to people who don't
have a verified tab you're able to sort
of see who follows you that are
influencers tweetbot another Twitter app
Google translate ups
llenza that is the airline AT&T passport
which I use when I travel abroad
postagram allows you to send postcards
from Instagram GoPro app Jiffy PayPal
SoundCloud hiking project is a really
cool hiking app it shows you local
hiking spots near you Flight Aware from
tracking flights Vine poke radar which
still sort of works Amtrak for getting
around bit Emoji Sephora Facebook
mentions Avery another photo eding app
some of these need I'm just I need to
redo a little reorganization results
this is kind of a cool it's a Runtastic
this wasn't actually I never used that
clearly that's not what I thought it was
Sky fit so this is kind of cool it's a I
guess different instructors will give
you different classes whether you're
running outside or on a treadmill or
elliptical or any of oh they even have
yoga too I've only done a few of the uh
treadmill classes and they're cool and
instructor will guide you through and
they have really cool playlists so
definitely a cool app but you do have to
pay for I think like a monthly
subscription um headspace is a
meditation app which is kind of amazing
I haven't done that enough but it's
really really cool especially if you're
a beginner meditator it'll walk you
through the steps it's super simple
Emoji maker never use that print I made
a video about that it was a print case
it's an iPhone case that you hook up to
your phone and it will print out photos
Apple TV remote DJI discover DJI go
Southwest nbot that's for my segue
Boomerang Starbucks odometer readings
imager skyfit already talked about that
Zillow my fitness pile clearly these
fitness apps are not getting used
squeegee which is um a Car Washing
Service they come and wash a car door
Dash food delivery spark some sort of
video editing thing that I never really
could figure out out folded is a really
fun game so you just drop these little
pieces on and you fold it out it's like
a little origami instacart how I get all
of my food delivered Nike run Club
iMovie Soo is a pretty awesome app it
basically a massage therapist will show
up to your house and give you a massage
you can do 60 Minutes or 90 minutes and
you can choose the type of massage that
you want to get look at this like this
is crazy eBay Peach I don't ever use
that feedback that's for the Apple
developers Jet Blue and task rabbit so
those
are those are my apps guys well tomorrow
is the day the iPhone 7 is out and I am
so excited I really can't wait let me
know if you guys have any favorite apps
I just showed you mine so feel free to
show me yours you can tweet them to me
at iine or that's really that's pretty
much how I see everything so cool you
want to leave me some comments on what
your favorite things are feel for you to
do that don't forget to subscribe hit
like if you like the video and I will
see you tomorrow for the iPhone 7
release
[Music]
bye